greetings good afternoon everyone thank you very much
for being in this presentation
today we will be reviewing or making a
summary of all the
pathological conditions that we see in prayers and
mainly from pathology that we see
in captive rhesus monkeys
that live in captivity and that is very
different from what would show
pathologies of animals that live in
nature,
as you can see here in this diagram,
the conditions that can cause
morbidity with mortality in
animals depend on many factors, as I
had mentioned, some of them
are
if the animals  They live in captivity or
live in the wild. Each one of
these diagrams of this circle
represents a different size, that is, they go
as you see in the case of animals in
captivity, since the causes of morbidity
and mortality are mainly
concentrated in the area of ​​inflammation.  or
infectious trauma and neoplasia and in other
aspects because sometimes we find
pathologies in the other categories but we are going to
be reviewing in general what
is common in the
rest of the population in the case of animals in
captivity here at the primate center
of the  caribbean
as you can see equipment is condition and
infection sea there are many things that
can cause inflammation infection in
animals including
hiral conditions material
conditions odd mitotic conditions as well picas
and as we have mentioned before
the categories of causes of disease
before depend on those factors and
depend  particularly for
infectious category diseases,
for example, if they are facilities that
keep jesus animals outdoors, that
is, they have some type of contact
with wild animals, whether they are
players of other animals, because
diseases that can be
transmitted from those animals must be considered  no to
animals in captivity, we
are going to start with a brief summary,
veiled with the viruses, it is of a determined DNA origin,
it is subdivided depending on its
external protein capacity and is also
subdivided by the type of envelope it
has, that is, the viscosity layer culture
weak and ask for this main one of greater
importance because there are the viruses of the
herpes and box group
what is that what you are not showing
some images
of the group of digital arts we have
three main categories the
beta raises them and the ranges of greater importance
that we have  What to know when we are
working with rhesus monkeys is the
pp virus because it is of the utmost
importance, naked from the causes it can
cause disease in humans and
usually the disease is lethal
if not treated with antivirals and there are
specialties that ultimately non-
humans exist  35 times in that in that
of a particular
emma cats met in the house without
service satisfaction or from riders
rhesus monkeys are usually an
asymptomatic infection, that is, they do not
have apparent oral lesions
in the mouth usually the lesions are
on the mucosa  they can also cause
conjunctivitis they can cause
genital ulcers and in some cases in one it
can visually cause encephalitis
when it is either a systemic virus dispersal
in this way usually the
animals have some other type of virus
that causes immunosuppression when the
virus is transmitted from  rhesus monkeys to
humans either by some route of
exposure some bite scratch
exposure to blood through gel
exposure
to urine for example if it falls into the eye
usually humans what
causes is lethal encephalitis so it
is  very important to emphasize that
pretty much back we assumed that all
rhesus monkeys have that
latent virus in their system that they can be
relaxed boiled at any time
so the safest practice is
simply to assume that all
waka names that have the virus have
the presence of the rhesus virus.  pp and
all the necessary precautions must be taken
when working with any fluid in the
world any
fresh fabrics in the world also
from the tops group is the most
important in terms of animals in
captivity that we are going to be talking about it will
be smallpox  from the ape monkeypox
design smallpox well they have a wide
range of hosts and this is why
from the mountains it can pass into the
worms so this is also another
virus they are a type
the last outbreak of design smallpox that
occurred in the united states which was  in
2003 it was practically
dispensed with by prairie dogs
in the usa several people got
infected i started with that virus and the
lesions are quite typical where having
a lesion that is a lesion is well
swollen the stone is elevated the skin
and  The classic thing is that it has like
a force that has an electro center
yes yes that is going to be a
typical lesion of monkeypox lesions it
can also disperse and systemically to the
lung
and they will see these lesions
similar to what  one sees in the skin in
the lung also
as you can see here is an
ecological section of a mosquito lesion in
this case you can see the degree of
necrosis in the skin it is
raised
hyperkeratosis there is degeneration of
which this was
and a classic lesson  in this case that is going to
have these viral inclusions that
can also be seen
logically so that would be one of
the structure I would ask pending to
find the viral inclusions
in the lessons here they can give that in
this case well there are some real grandchildren to
work the point  1 where they can
potentially pass it on to you or either a
secondary vector that has been
exposed to
a dream ball that they can
pass it on to humans so they don't
necessarily pass it on or not and
they can see the progression within a
week you can see the la  progression of
these lesions
the classic lesion that you can see on the
right hand which is the center the
necrotic center of the point is electronic like
a with a navel which would be the
classic detox
virus lesion is of origin of sn and rn as
you can see the subdivision is  it
all depends on how those proteins are regulated
around the
genetic material so if they have an
envelope usually the viruses are that they do not
have an envelope they tend to be a
little more resistant in the
rural and potentially harsh environment
image in the environment and  be more
resistant disinfectant so you have
to keep that pending column is
working with an outbreak because it is
trying to control the civilization
of an infectious agent
to give an example of each
of these writings of the different
categories
for example here in the
primate center las rabies because a real risk
in puerto rico rabies is
mainly transmitted by mongoose so
we have a natural reservoir that
continuously because it is a risk for
animal expenses so we made sure
to provide him with the rabies vaccine
anyway it turned out that  They are also
susceptible like any other
mammal
to any other species in particular. We
are going to be teaching more lessons about
measles or the mysterious ones and the
virus of a skill that is the living
example of that is a group that would be the
hanta virus that mainly
transmit it.  The suppliers, at least
here in Puerto Rico, have never described
a case in any kind of
hanta virus, it has not been identified and,
like the arena virus, no
cases of inj and red and itchy studies have been seen,
but it is something  Since we are exposed
to gambling, it is something that whenever we are
doing the necropsies and evaluating those
tissues, we should have it as a
differential if we find cases that
start either with encephalitis, in the
case of specific meningitis, or
if we find cases with
some respiratory symptoms, then we should
keep in mind their differentials
in
this group the category of influences if it
has been documented that
the influence can be transmitted mainly
here our our
main concern would be that it be transmitted from
human to the modules mes and that we
usually have to ask the
staff  who is working who
feels the symptoms of
influence flows simply do not come to
work that time until they are
fully recovered be with
friends
as it happens in other species because
they can cause these
gastrointestinal symptoms just like the
other davids or
us here well  We
particularly have a problem of
exposure to viruses with encephalon
myocarditis, so we see
sporadic cases of sex, myocarditis that is
transmitted by rodents, so we
are seeing, although there are
rodent viruses, we have to have the type of facility
that we have here that if there is contact with
wildlife although we keep in
check the providers if
a diverse civilization of
rodents is occurring to affect a population of
the new sporadically
in the case of the suits
none s
originally found in in africa
but recently headquarters it was announced that
that in being Martin on the island daughter
leaving you, sporadic cases have already been seen
that are being transmitted
through the bite of mosquitoes that
are not people who come from Africa to
visit Salamanca and are not people who
are in San  martín that the
rogues although the local mosquitoes and
develop infection with the
chick virus deceives mainly symptoms are
comfortable flower but chronically it can
result in chronic inflammation of
the joints a serious and chronic polis
that is chronic so
cases have already been identified  on the island of d
more and more virgins and the virgins
also near puerto rico so they are
something that eventually we hope that the
movement of that of that virus will
eventually reach puerto rico and
you can not only have it as a
differential of symptoms from uruguay  in
human or differential management backdrop
with symptoms of fever fever and could
critical and more but also in
jesus monkeys because rhesus monkeys
are also susceptible to developing
viral infection and developing
critical julia so that's something that
as we're doing  our
necropsies, which is something that we are going to have
as an indifference and thus we find
outbreaks of e.coli arthritis in the
population of about 15 of the
rhesus monkeys
and then yes, we know that
monkeys are not susceptible to tongues but they
can develop antibodies  and not
developing a fulminant condition
so detect that there is the
ability to transmit that
particular virus at 13 in total this
is there and praise weaknesses because it
was always yellow and since the nile
at least we have not seen
dominant or decisive cases of the virus  of the
Nile but here in Puerto Rico
other species have also been affected,
particularly horses that are more
susceptible, so if it is something that
we have in mind and not 2011, what
more than the moment has been studied due to
its similarity with the with the hb
and all the information that can be obtained
with an investigation of this virus, in
particular immunodeficiency agent in
monkeys,
measles or the same in English,
are typically skin lesions
that are erythematous erythemas or the
lesions themselves, mainly what
is sought in  This pathology is
the bone nonsense, the multinucleated cells
that are mainly located
in the area of ​​the follicles. It would be
good if this pathology is done. In this
case, you
could appreciate
that particular lesson.
This had not previously been mentioned by you about
the closed virus.
you lost and that it is transmitted by
rodents in a type of cardio virus it is
an itch nothing ticona virus a
live cardio is extremely resistant in the
environment that is, it resists drying out and
resists this cold so it usually
remains well viable at -81 180
degrees  So yes,
then they have to think about if there is an
environment contaminated with this virus, disinfection
must be carried out
with one of the
control measures in addition to the control of the
suppliers,
who mainly maintains the virus
in nature and as a natural reservoir.
typical that we see in these animals that we
look good today and tomorrow
morning you find the soul of the dead person in
the cage
and you practically do not see any other
symptom that produces me and before the
animal dies, yes that is
typical of the  art we open a
ribcage is that they are lungs that
collapses the liver tends to be
very dark well swollen it is reddish and the
heart tends to pale
this in this pathology what
we tend to see in the lung is a
pulmonary edema  in severe that
practically does not give him time to
develop any type of information, he
also thinks about hormonal and
hepatic congestion and simply because
acute heart failure occurs and if there is
inflammation present in the heart,
then another section of the lung with
severe edema that  The death of the animal itself is
due to a combination of the
diffuse edema found in this in the
lung and also when the
heart failure and as you can see here what is
typical in the small right hand image
is the severe lung cream
found  In the nasal passages, that
would be the first sign and we know that
we have a problem or a suspect
for encephalomyelitis, so the typical thing
we do is that we check for the presence
of the virus or not in the tissues of the
heart, as the
name of the virus demonstrates.  It is an encephalomyelitis, it
can also cause encephalitis, but in
the cases that we have seen here, it
usually does not give time for it to
develop in the part of the
brain inflammation, so usually
a death due to the
virus infection in the cardiomyocytes and due to the
annoying chemical  you
can see the nest in the cell in
the years foci of inflammation in the
heart
other infections that are of great
importance that play a very
important role in the management of the population
are bacterial infections within
that category since tuberculosis is
usually the  Animals are
asymptomatic and when they are
developing the symptoms of coughing,
very similar to what happens to
humans later, then it is that they are
transmitting per day, they left only the
bacteria in the environment and that is where
it would be magical, so as a
preventive and
Monkey population monitoring resurfaces in captivity as
tuberculin tests are done on them and
anyone
who is in direct contact or
working indirectly with monks
or not entering facilities is
required to
bring evidence to a mob
Negative tuberculin so we can be
sure that we have some kind of
control and completely prevent
transmission of 2-node tuberculosis to
thick walls so the
typical tuberculosis lesion has been a
solid yellowish mass
consisting mainly of a group  of
macrophages, this and those macrophages in their
cytoplasm, because they will have the bacteria
that can be identified with special inks,
whenever we talk about tuberculosis,
we tend to think that it simply affects
the lungs, but it does not only affect
the lungs that are uncomfortable.  and
sometimes, well, you can enter, you can
reach different organs of the body, and
as you can see in this image,
here is this vessel and each corner,
we the kidneys, so it
can also manifest itself systemically,
so in order to verify this,
we have the option of different
molecular tests.  the histology or the cytology
but the constant of the or the
confirmation test this would be the cultures
but usually well that bad touch
that takes months another other bacterium
that is extremely important and is actually
found everywhere
in the soil in  all surfaces
even can be found in the
secret is the clostridium tetani here
we have a photo of the real case of the
serious ones this animal had not been
vaccinated yet just like it is
in our facilities but
the facilities of callo santiago this
development  the
typical condition of this condition is the posture
of this type of posture
in extension without being able to move so they
usually present with
difficulties walking and then
progressively they may have difficulties
catching food they may have
difficulties swallowing until
they eventually die from
respiratory failure but  there are treatments and
the way we can work
with the following at the center is
to make sure that we provide the vaccine for
other bacterial conditions that are
very common would be the following
knife infections here we have
an image on the internet of a
segment tract  of the colon you can see that there is
a fairly large area with with fiber
mixed with its healing and all the
darker areas of necrosis and
ulceration and hemorrhage so this is
serious
but as the classic presentation of
an infection gets the so it
can be confirmed by  means of octopus something
also by means of
molecular tests such as the teaser the lungs
that from this same case we can see that
the distribution is from an edema to a
dorsal conviction the caudal that is
consistent with great sepsis so what is
typical of these animals  that they
can also develop sepsis
and
in the historical section we can we can
appreciate the degree of observation that there is we
have a bilayer that
consists mainly of fibrin that
consists of the
necrotic material and we can also see
rage the mainly
inflammatory cells that are found this  in
this area these neutrophils but there
may also be this macrophage associated with
the lesion if the animal survives the
infection it can be
a chronic animal that then
the bacteria will be arriving
sporadically depending on whether in
times of stress so it
is  It is important to identify those animals
that may be infected with the
bacteria that may be a source for
that other animals that have not been
previously exposed that
may then develop the migratory condition
so that other conditions that cause
diarrhea both water stress and doubts.
10 chronic cattle campylobacter
cantilo buster is one of those bacteria
that is considered that wine
is necessarily natural from the remains
that can originate from humans just
like shigella but
once it is in the population then
the only one is transmitted  from one to the other, as you
can see here, it is not the digestive tract,
it is simply distended, it is full
of gas, it does not open in a
liquid soil, it
is typical for those of us who camp or
buster, these monkeys with
chronic and chronic campylobacter and many
times many times  they lose weight and that
too because of the risk that
they develop other conditions like milo
and 12 simply because they have
chronic inflammation
the digestive tract in this image is
a more chaotic image of the wizard text and
we can see that there are many nodules in the
mucosa so this  This is a great
gastritis, an example,
chronic follicular gastritis, that is, all these
are sols and culs of the lymphocyte.
Typically, this lesion is thought to be with
Helicobacter, for example, in humans, it is
thought that Helicobacter is
linked to what can cause gastric tumors.
I believe that in Recife this has not been
verified, this has not been identified,
but they can. Helicobacter el Monk is
a problem that can cause gastritis,
chronic gastritis
in these, here it seems that there is a
question, yes,
glu qik,
although the elements that allow about
the elements  of personal protection
I try to work with one
bruce a year since according to a presentation there
are many shifts and the possibility
that we also transmit
diseases
so in terms of
personal protection the best thing that I can
recommend is to use
eye protection mask usually the
masks that have more
in categories such as the name of the n95
that, for example, they can prevent
bacteria such as tuberculosis from breathing in, so
the most important thing is to protect the skin and
mucous membranes
with that protective gas mask to
avoid breathing any
infectious agent, they also come with marc masks
that  They filter the air that has a
hepa filter that can filter any
type of
viral particles, whether they are
small viral or
bacterial particles and use more
specific designated clothing for driving and
when you are working with
specific overalls when one is doing a
necropsy, well, this  It would always be good
to take into account that you need
good gloves that you avoid if you are
working with if you are not doing a
necropsy you are not working with
knives and sharp objects because having
a part called Kirchner del
América which is what prevents a person from
passing through  of the one blade is not going to
prevent being struck by this syringes
but it can prevent this cut on a
blade so at least three
gloves three levels of gloves use
some sort of respiratory protection and
bloody eye membrane protection
hopefully  that answers the question in
other bacterial conditions it is
often difficult for us to identify the
causes of deaths and from witnesses to see
where failure and reproductive morals with
during pregnancy but one of the
most common causes
donald since there are many factors that
can result in the loss of  a fetus
but one of the most common ones that we
can identify are
ascending infections of the globe in fetuses so they
are usually
ascending infections of bacteria that come
from the same rectum that go up the entire vagina
and continue to the cervix it is not good it will be that
those bacteria can  enter the
placenta and after the placenta there may
be access to the amniotic fluid and
the fetus, because basically in its
exercise of these breathing excluded
from the amniotic fluid itself
it can be infected with a bacterium and that is
what we were seeing here in the
histological section  all the blue areas
no salviolo this may be full of
bacteria and inflammation so not
necessarily a bruising pattern not of
transmission in general kills and insects
but one of respiratory transmission
via that same exercise of breathing
amniotic fluid I have another question
here
Although I think that this context is ok,
so this other
bacterial diseases can cause sepsis also,
going to rhesus monkeys, here we can see some
external manifestations of sepsis in a
baby that we can see is in that area and
burning
in the skin right in the nail and  Also, if
moto2 is examined to the whole mind, in
this module the
mucosa of the oral cavity was also dark.
In this case, the animal had
meningitis and we can see that
the meninges are yellowish and in the
cytology we can see
and  an acute inflammation mainly
of neutrophils and this was due to
sepsis due to a live icon
and here we can see the
ecological section with neutrophils
in the meninges
other infectious conditions as there are
mythical and fungal conditions in
this case a candida albicans is
quite  common if you have if you are
working on projects that was
not suppressing candida well it
can be a problem
sometimes it also occurs especially in
these animals chronic diarrhea they
are probably not getting all
the nutrients they need and they have
infections not just from  camps and
don't spend or other bacteria they have
candida infections as well so
this one as you can see here on the tongue
has a white coating it's practically a pseudo
membrane that when
we examine this logically you
can see all the ffaa practically
invading the tissue in  Some cases
can be systemic and you can go to other
internal organs,
but usually the amount is really
part of the normal flora. If the
animal has some type of
immunosuppressive condition, then it is that
these animals this amount is
short until they go back, so
usually when we see candida we try
to look for other factors that contribute
to immunosuppression in these
animals whether viral or bacterial or
any other nutrition even so
here we can see in this
silver tint this same see the
fifa invading invading tissue
diseases  parasitic because
rhesus monkeys have many
parasitic diseases, some of which can be news
or well - I believe that the vast
majority of them
are just tic in this case we have
a lung of an adult jesus and we can
see many nodules through the tissue
of all the nodules and one of the
differentials that you have to have if you don't see
a lung like this is this tuberculosis so
this must always be kept
in mind that
particular differential but usually when you feel
this these foci in this body are not
generally empty  or they are full of
air the presentation can be a
little variable as you can see here but they
are all this kit is like mites so they
are empty they are full of
air and dependency the car is dead
it cannot be that they are full of
inflammation
but there is  to have as a differential in
the most solid foci and the yellowish ones
that it is not going to be a tuberculosis lesion
so as you can see here here there are
a few that are and they most
likely watch these in these photos the mites
are live and  they are quite
large and the mites in turn
the life cycle is not
completely described but it is believed that it
is due to all direct contact so
they can cause a lot of damage to the
respiratory tract as we can see here
in the bronchi
in  the sections and theology that you
can appreciate the finish within those
foci those foci there is quite a lot the
book is still associated with them you
can even find many oenophile
mixed inflammation can even be
found in the cross I do this
multi nucleated in these trichuris moles
this  It is quite common in the population
if trichuris is not dewormed periodically
and it can be one of the causes
of diarrhea and for this reason it is important
to do the discrete examination in
animals with diarrhea in addition to being
cultured and peeled the excreta cultures
of this one so  Here, for example, they have
an adult Trichuris in
mythological sections that is quite classic for this one
for nematodes and usually it
occurs among males because they have are
quite different from other
protozoans in this case a protozoan
that is not dealt with, this one that is quite
infectious  and
only tico is the described toribio that are
noted on the surfaces of the entire
milestones and usually press cause is
atrophied diffusion of the
hairs on the surface of the mucosa
this and then results in
severe diarrhea that can affect if not  If it is not
treated or if the animal becomes dehydrated
enough,
this other interesting parasite that we
found in the population of two of
their in Callo Santiago can cause death, they leave Trico
alone, which is found in the nose on the
leg.  in the nose and that has also been
described as a parasite only type
other diseases of a
nutritional or metabolic nature that affect
monkeys in captivity are in the
conditions
and not greasy the typical thing about this variable is
that you cannot find it you can be
observing  They look good, an animal
that is in good health,
this good weight, but if they are in a group and
are obese animals that stop running for the moment,
then assimilate the cat, it
begins to use fats in such a
way that they develop the
fatty liver condition so the first thing
one sees when one opens the skin is this
focus of fat necrosis so it's
quite typical in this case
here we have the man plunge into these
electron pockets and the increase in
la  diffuse accumulated fat in the diffuse
mind of the modules of the like and
also of the kidney as you do not examine it and
all logically in the kidney section
and you can see all the accumulation of
fluid in the in the
epithelial cells of the tubules
in this  case here we have a section of the
liver you can see the accumulation of
lipids through all the deposits
here in this one in which it is located in
particular that we have evidence of
adipocyte necrosis yes carlotto
little of this in these cases is that we see
in a  acute presentation usually
this high art
because of this mortality are animals
that are obese that are female macaques
are usually stressed and go through a
period of stress that is a change of
group a movement of cage or
simply they are not letting us
eat for  team of reason or this the age
older than nine years
there is where it comes to be another of the
very common conditions is that we see here they
usually do not develop secondary to
chronic inflammation we can see that in
the liver in many of these animals sometimes
they have a  Severe formulation resulting
in quite severe atrophy of the hepatocytes,
impressively, we
will have many changes in it, many
changes in the blood plaque.
It is something that we find incidents that
incidentally can accumulate
amyloidosis in other organs, that is, they
can develop systemic amyloidosis
in the previous image, it was
the adrenal gland, here we have a
section of the small intestine,
this intestine, which also accumulates amyloidosis,
which then prevents digestion and
absorption.  of nutrients here we have the
vessel and we can see that the vessel also
this develops that appearance this
zero ssa ib and firm this that is classic
and you can see here that all the
white door of the vessel has been replaced by
deposits of amyloidosis amyloidosis and
also like  It commonly occurs in the
kidney, as you can see here in the
typical care to identify
amyloidosis, it is the Congo Red, which gives you
one using certain filters in the
microscope because it gives you a light that
reflects this green light and that
confirms that it is  an
accumulation of friends and also
commonly in animals we can
find atherosclerosis plaques
can extend even in the
very nutritionally it is
extremely important to provide
rhesus monkeys with vitamin c otherwise
they can develop
fragile blood vessels and that is where
come those hemorrhagic lesions
associated with vitamin c deficiency
blunt trauma extremely common in
the population of the remains are
aggressive animals usually females are the ones
that tend to attack each other and
tend to cause this type of
blunt trauma so what
What happens is that tiny work is done,
as you can see here everything
logically you can see all the
acute necrosis of that muscle,
all those enzymes then end up in the
union and as a cause of that,
we end up with kidney failure, so
many of these cases end up  on the
autopsy table secondary to the
end of life failure
in my glory or the accumulation of this
protein in the kidney this
can also be radically found in
cases of sepsis and thus exists due to
bacterial infections this of the
nature of the being of the bacterial nature
to  Sometimes we can find
extremely clear aneurysms in this case we have
a grace a hemorrhage that
extended into the mediastinum
and was due to a
pulmonary artery aneurysm there
can also be this
vascular accidents in the brain are not very
common
but the purely  you can
find those cases of
degenerative disorders of these bone animals
had their pores and
degenerative arthritic conditions these from the oasis
in animals if they have been castrated it is not the
reason why they should not be
given to rhesus monkeys is that they can
develop this loss of more  of
bone mass as you can see here on the
right hand side there is a normal bone
compared to a bone from an animal that
was castrated so they can develop
these conditions similar to humans
they can develop
degenerative arthritis here is the head of the
femur and they can  see the degree of
cartilage loss that is found sometimes
this can be a little
rossi it is harmful that they can lose
a lot of
feeling to the joint cartilage resulting
in these animals not being able to use
their hind legs
sometimes monkeys are similar to
humans they can  develop this
chronic theme that consists of this
proliferation of tissue and classification
but usually for this reason in the south not
just this old also occasionally
because these lesions are found
and this
endocardial sis that are lesions in the
mitral valves is more common 20
neoplastic conditions are  also
quite common mainly what
we do in our population of monkeys
are the local ones but as we can
see here where of what is and no
more cause this typical this typical
lesion
we have a dilatation of the intestine
prior to the focus of cancer in the
intestine is  more column in the
blind sky but we can also see it in the
small intestine and in the lincoln but
the typical thing about this lesion of origin from
which the epithelial cells
of the mucosa originate is that it can be extremely
invasive and end in 252
we can also  see neoplasms of origin
I felt bad in this case it was a monkey
with multiple masses in the joint
all of which were consistent with a
synovial tumor as we can see there when it was
cut that tissue had a lot of
viscosity this the matrix in libya its
slab was that would be that
viscous consistency so a tumor of
mesenchymal origin this
of the joints in that
particular monkey sometimes we see other
more rare and primitive tumors in the
brain as we can see here I'm going to
give you a little faster
the embryonic tissue that are just
it's  rare but since we have so
many animals here sometimes we come
across these rarer cases, they can be
done in our clinics to
define it a little more and to be able to determine
what type of cancer they are in that example
this skies carcinoma was curious and no
more than  tea from the liver are not common but
can be found sporadically and
almost normal from the ovary is like for
example here but we have that there were all
other conditions that resemble or
behave like cancers having
the same metrics and that is extremely
common in rhesus monkeys  and all that we
are seeing here what a dark
brown color these are the chocolate cysts
so
the ones that are used as a model of
endometriosis which is a condition well
combining normal
and this logically well this is quite
classic here we have but we can see the
number and  vegeta and in between
solutions are also working
through those of endometriosis growth
and there it is, it would be the
classic mythology of an endometriosis lesion,
this one that can also cause
obstruction construction in the canaries
image demetriosis if endometriosis well
depends on the degree  In this case, we have
a severe case of endometriosis, it all
depends on the state that is found,
other conditions, quite a bit, with
gastric dilatations in monkeys that
can cause an acute sample. This can
be caused. It is thought to be
caused by clostridium, but it has not been
possible to verify.  Still, there is usually
no pain, that is, there is no, there is no
movement of the
stomach line, simply a
severe dilation, this is a quite common prolapse in
the teeth, instructions, which
can also cause
acute necrosis in animals, as you can see
here, which are extremely  I bring them
I think that it is accumulations of hair that
can infect the intestine
and injuries can occur sporadically
because the causes have not been very well defined,
such as
myopathy in the modes and
theologically we tend to see a little
truck comes enlarged with what is
enlarged but  In other versions, in the
sinologist it has been possible to identify that
perhaps stress has a role in
these cardiomyopathy but it doesn't really work out for us,
we don't really know what
causes it, so this is the series like
classical histology would highlight
homeopathy, there is fibrosis.  it is there the
cardiomyocytes are enlarged it may
be that sometimes they find inflammation
intensifies other times it is not but it is
quite common in other
congenital conditions malformations such as others
born inferior that produce it in this
case that it is pallets
in this excess that most likely
would have this  They also had other
congenital conditions and other
extremely rare torrent headaches in
which we have not had only two cases
and the and the fact that they are bilateral and
in this case we have to be a failure in
the occipital lobes these monkeys were
since they were born  this blind man and it is
believed that they may be family members it is trauma
during the process of the perfect plan
it can can cause this type of
injury but usually they are
unilateral injuries and they are not and they are not bilateral it is
that a bilateral injury does not do more more
it is rare
and these do not give us  They tend to have a
smaller brain,
this one, and here we have an example of
scoliosis, which could also be
congenital, but it is from birth,
here I have a list of the references
that were used,
I wanted to take this opportunity to let you
know that here we have an
extremely  The
morphology and genetics laboratory of the
Caribbean Primate Center
on the Medical Sciences Campus at the
University of Puerto Rico is useful, where
all kinds of studies
related to bone pathologies can be carried out.
We have a collection of more than 2,000
bones and we have access to all the
genealogy to all the to all the
genetics
to all the information related to that
so it is extremely useful as a
source of research and that it is
available to people who are
interested in any type of
pathology of  bone so I wanted to
take advantage and thank all the
sponsors for this opportunity I
hope you enjoyed the
presentation
you have I will be answering
questions if you have any
good
because I see that there is a question here
what are the most
common applications of monkeys  rhesus as an
animal model thanks this right now
monkey gestures are being used a lot for hb studies as
they are susceptible they have their
own this immunodeficiency virus
is used as a model for studies
with hb but any other study
either  This development, for example, there are
some studies that are being carried
out on
the circadian rhythm of this
bone pathology, particularly if they are associated
with genetic conditions such as osteopenia,
osteoporosis,
this is really the rhesus monkey that
has many applications in those
aspects of
transnational research.
but mainly today excessive
research decided
and this
presentations will be available
with all the images will be
available through the website of various
light conflicts if they want to cut me
contact us they can
contact the email that the
person who was interested in
writing to me at that time only  I can
provide it
and
light